you look beautiful darling so
cute i figured since i didn't have the
pink hair anymore i had to give a little
pink wink to miss julie
exactly right and speaking of miss julie
she uh
she's a young lady with very few
boundaries so i gotta ask like what
what's so thrilling about playing a
young lady that's so
free and was there a scene in particular
that was your favorite
oh goodness i mean each scene that julie
threw herself into for lack of a better
word but
it it brought a fun and an exciting
element a lot of things i've never done
before on a set a lot this is definitely
a character unlike any that i've played
um and i sort of see her as the perfect
intersection of
you know erin brockovich harley quinn
elle woods and villanelle
in a way she's this manic tinkerbell of
the apocalypse which gave me so much to
do
and play with and especially you know a
lot of my time was spent with
nat wolfe and alex skarsgard and fiona
dwarf and all these people who just
bring so much to every character
um but for me it it really was
amazing to just get to jump in and play
a character like this having played
superheroes for the last several years
right exactly
citizens of new vegas from the ashes of
captain trips
we have risen it's what happens now
you have a choice we all have a choice
oh i just it was such a thrilling show
i can't wait to see the rest of the
season because we only got that we got a
taste of it with the first four episodes
so i need to get back for more
but you know i'm wondering how is the
coronavirus pandemic
how has it impacted your outlook at the
series considering
timing which has just been unbelievable
and how do you think it might now
resonate with audiences
it's almost i don't want to say
fortuitous but in a way
it's it's perfect timing for a story
like this and i even felt that before
the pandemic
because aside from being about a disease
the stand is really about
humanity and about society and you know
all of us have had so much time this
year to really reassess and rethink the
way that we interact with the world and
the way that we interact with each other
and the way that we treat each other and
a lot of that comes up in this story
and you know for better for worse
people's true colors come out when
they're put in adverse circumstances and
we see that in each of these characters
and
how they react and how they decide they
fit into this new normal is really
indicative
of who they are as people so stephen
king he is an interesting guy
that is to say the least right there and
he has been thrilling
and scaring us for so many decades now
so i've got to ask you
what is the one thing that you are truly
afraid of okay this is gonna sound well
i'll give you a serious answer and a
silly answer um in all
seriousness this year has brought a lot
of that to the surface for me because uh
stagnance is probably my biggest
real fear of not growing not learning
not
taking advantage of every opportunity
and and seeing what life can bring
and this year has sort of forced me to
pause and
figure out new creative ways of doing
that and of staying productive
but as far as irrational fears um
my biggest fear is dropping something
down an elevator shaft
like something important whether it's
you know uh something special to you or
like your keys or a phone or something
down that little crack as you step into
an elevator i don't know why but ever
since i was little every time i step
into an elevator i kind of catch my
breath
because of that i'm gonna i'm gonna
think twice the next time i get on an
elevator now i'm gonna think about that
crack and think about you you can't
i'm sorry i've given you something else
to fear this product